what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y oh man Sophia broke her nail my real
nail not even a fake one so I'll do the
intro hello everybody and welcome back
to another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sister and
Sophia yay we switch it up today now I'm
how bad that look there actually is
nothing worse than a broken nail I know
it sounds dramatic but truly it's a big
deal no it's you know what the problem
is is because I've been doing those fake
gel X's for a long time and I swear to
God since I've taken them off my nails
are like look how short they're and I'm
not by way I'm not cutting them short
they just keep falling off so weak
there's two types of girls right the
natural short nail
and the long cat claws that I have on my
hands this is so ugly I cannot even I
really badly want to be you that kind of
girl the natural small Nails except I
feel like they look so naked I look like
I have little ches no I want to be you
why would you say that like that now I
don't want to be
you no but do you know what I mean I
want to be you because I like having
pretty
I can't I can't keep doing it so you use
do you have do you have um the stuff on
top to then paint over like I use my
real nails no no no cuz that peels the
real nail off well that's why my nails
are falling off I can't keep up though
cuz now there's the whole Russian
manicure which what's that sounds fancy
and I kind of want you you know the
beauty trends I know the wellness Trends
oh you're s sinee almost threw up in the
elevator when I told her what I was
doing um for my necks Health Trend so I
was gagging actually disgusting as we
all know your girl has cystic acne
popping up as we know I have EA cystic
acne and a broken nail no but I mean
makeup does wonders and thankfully it's
actually slowed down but suddenly I woke
up yesterday with two massive ones on my
face that really hurt so um I've been of
course going to not the doctor but to
the doctors of Tik Tok to find out how
to fix this and so some girl said that
uh having a spoonful of seamoss gel
every morning on an empty stomach is the
way to go so um it basically I can't
even explain the the way I explained it
to the I don't think it it's a little
TMI on this but it's it's like a it's
like sushi tasting cuz it's all salty um
and let's just say it's a cloudy white
color and let's just say that it also
has like a Jell-O thicker texture not
like a Jello-O texture it's like thicker
than jello
um so you have a spoonful of that and
we're playing a game of code names right
now like you can say everything but what
you're actually trying to say I don't
want to say like you said it was like a
salty cloudy
pudding but thick and chill now you see
why I gagged in the elevator yeah and I
have now I'm trying to do it every
morning oh how do you think I felt this
morning okay I have I have something to
say yes I think all of these Tik Tock
Health well
Trends I do think it's a little bit of a
hoax a little bit of a money grab so the
girl that showed a photo of her before
skin and after skin and the last page
was the Z how do you not know she's not
drinking a gallon of water every day
doing apple cider vinegar shots only
eating clean you never know I'm doing
the toric shots I'm doing the sea moss
gel I'm doing the gallon of water a day
my question is celery juice why torture
yourself my stomach really hurts that's
what I'm saying well because you don't
have what I have right now so I'm trying
to but I all I know at the end of the
day what it really is is my stress
levels I just need to calm that down but
I refuse because I've been a high
functioning anxiety person for the
longest time and I can't break down now
I have to keep this going go to therapy
stop saying go to therapy I don't need a
therapist I know what my thing is my
thing is is that I just don't know to
calm myself down I don't need to tell
like I don't need to hear someone say
calm down you know like I don't need to
work through anything I know what I need
I know you know what funny that as I was
saying that and I heard myself
back you know how certain things become
part of your personality it's like a
little bit of a oneup on you therapy is
now part of my personality like I think
I'm better than you cuz I go to therapy
which is not true I also think being a
New Yorker is my personality now it's
not but tell me
that tell me that when you don't talk to
people the first 10 minutes of your
conversation is about you living in New
York like it's your personality kind of
kind of yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like a
new outfit okay I want to talk I want to
talk about something that has really
been keeping me up at night and you know
I've pondered a lot and I've really done
some inner deep work and I've come to
the conclusion that I give up I give up
no that's fair I give up on what you
might ask well last week's episode I was
really excited because I had two dates
lined up we called him Mr Friday and Mr
Saturday I was so excited I thought
these both these guys are checked out
they look great responding well all is
good we were excited they had a solid
age they had solid jobs they seemed like
they were responsive decent to look at
decent to look at all the stars were
aligning yeah where should I begin Mr
Friday yes
well oh
gosh we decide to meet up at a bar and
during this time of year in New York if
you don't have a reservation you're not
getting it anywhere yeah I really didn't
understand when people were saying that
before how crucial it is it's impossible
something booked four months ahead of
time it's impossible so first place
didn't work out then I said okay let's
meet at this place the second place
didn't work out across the street from
the second place there was this divey
dive dive bar and I said let's just go
there I don't care I just want to sit
somewhere and talk to you like I don't
care where we go right and we go to the
hostess stand and the guy's looking at
me like well I don't think we have and I
said sir I like pulled him in I was like
please it's our first date PRS him by
the collar I did please I said it's our
first [__] date man help a girl out
okay the one thing I will say is when
you saw him at first glance you're like
okay he's not badl looking and then she
described him I don't know if you guys
have watched suits she said he sounds
like Harvey Spectre yeah which like that
kind of deep demanding voice you're like
o Hees not have a deep voice at all no
just just a powerful presence right yeah
so I begged the hostess he said oh God
let me help you we get seated right away
it seems to be going well um you know
there's a few things that I look for in
the beginning of a first date within the
first five minutes of your I always
think it's polite to say you know I'm so
happy we're meeting up or you look
really nice tonight or I'm glad we could
do this something to just just say like
I'm happy to be here too yeah just like
something right I said he looked
handsome he didn't say anything back
listen I'm not one of those girls that
is like pulling for a compliment but
you're like I put in two hours I did put
in two hours like come on come on so we
sit down the conversation's flowing I
want to give credit to myself
and he didn't ask me any questions fine
so what do I do I keep asking questions
cuz the conversation would lag otherwise
but even with that happening I still
felt like okay there was some funny
banter like he had this sort of
Personality where he doesn't really give
an f and he just
was saying whatever was on his mind
which I kind of likeed that you like the
no filter yeah that repertoire back and
forth and then he
said you know you look familiar what do
you
do I said what do you do well I said I
have a podcast with my
sister I you know have a show on he goes
whoa whoa whoa whoa are you famous are
you famous of wait that makes hold
on hold on I knew I knew who you were
this the thing even if you knew there's
a 100 ways you can approach this and it
can be 10,000 times better but it's just
like you can totally just say this oh
cool what's the show about no that's it
but it's here's the thing he was playing
it off like he didn't know anything
about me going into it which I kind of
appreciated and I don't think personally
when Sophia and I go out I don't think
people know us and I still don't think
people know us actually I I get if
people stare at me and I get kind of why
are they they don't know us they know
our dad right and so we're pretty much
attached in that realm he kept egging me
on and saying are you famous you look
famous who's your family who's your
family are you famous and I said I don't
even know how to answer that and I said
well I'm not um my parent is and he goes
oh Sylvester Stallone oh that's how I
know you all stuff and then goes into a
30 minute
fangirling moment talking about how Sly
was brought up in Hell's Kitchen I just
watched the documentary Copland is my
favorite movie telling me things about
my dad that I already know I already
know oh God but this is the thing it's
okay to be a fan but would you want us
to go on a 50-minute tangent by your
father that's what I tried to by the way
I love your dad he's such a great
dentist every single too he's filled
perfect that's what I tried to do I cut
him off he said what does your dad do
let's talk about your dad and he was
like my dad uh yeah but then he went
right back to Sly so I thought okay and
then he started sort of cutting me down
and what I do and he goes well that Mak
sense why you do this or why you have a
podcast or why whatever because of him
has he been on a date before and I don't
think he maybe he realized that was
pretty insulting but I still rolled with
it but you know steam started billowing
out of my ears say he had no filter at
this point too I was going off that was
strike one with him strike two was the
no questions strike three Mr funny guy
Friday was saying something funny to my
face don't even remember what the line
was he said something like I really want
to be in a relationship then St I can't
even say it like I can't even he looked
at me and said I want to be in a
relationship then stared straight at my
tits and said I want to be in a
relationship he's like I don't think
they heard it no but he was like
growling like like like like he wanted
to jump in there I have
never okay all right and and here's
strike four here's strike four at this
point I was I was ready to make a run
for it well he's like the boobs have a
brain of themselves here but here's
strike four
remember how he said he acted like I was
a total stranger but then he secretly
knew everything about me he also thought
it would be a good idea towards the end
of our date to bring up other men that
I've gone on dates
with first and last names how do you
know this
information do you know especially the
ones that he was bringing up was pretty
Rogue I don't post people I go on dates
with I don't even follow people I go on
dates with how do you know stalker
stalker stalker all right flag what I
did was I run to the bathroom this is
also a really good hack for any ladies
out there that are like I got to get out
of here and it's not wrapping up and he
keeps ordering another cocktail I go to
the
bathroom I passed the waiter on the way
there and I said please bring the check
to the table I go to the bathroom I call
Sophia I said where the hell are you she
said I'm here she sends me her address I
call an Uber in the bathroom
all right by the time I got out of the
bathroom the bill was there paid for
that was the only good thing Mr Friday
did bar and paid for Uber was already
outside ran for it done horrible yeah
and also haven't even heard from him
since I thought I did a great job T best
part you know what he probably thought
he did bad yeah I I think he has a
feeling that he didn't do that great I
mean Sophia he even talked about his
exes I mean it was like on and Ian I I
mean I I went on a date not date when I
was in Palm Beach like remember a couple
weeks a coffee thing where I didn't even
realize it was a date yeah but he
thought it was immediately within the
first two minutes talking about his ex
for the last for the next hour I'm like
just don't look this is just not a
dating just don't just don't um it's
just it's just not it it's just not it
let's talk about Mr Saturday oh God and
this was the one she was more excited
about totally yeah we had some witty
banter over text I felt really good
about this one he was more my type looks
wise he was the one that was new to the
city new to the city I was like I feel
good about Mr Saturday so I woke up
Saturday morning sprung out of bed I
said you know what Friday night was a
fail it can't get worse than Friday
night I'm excited I'm ready I don't feel
bad I don't feel bogged
down
now typically when you go on a date with
someone there should be a followup prior
to the date yeah just hey looking
forward to tonight either a day before
the day of even a few hours before just
to sort of remind that person yeah
what's happening I haven't spoken to Mr
Saturday Saturday in about six or seven
days well no no it was no I was like
days it was Tuesday the date was
Saturday okay yeah okay four days five
days still the plan was also loose it
wasn't a booked reservation it was a oh
let's meet at this bar it was a loose
plan now I start getting ready early
right and can I just say sometimes
ladies you know when you do your makeup
and it just slays like you looked at
yourself differently today and you're
like whoa everything just came together
perfectly she came into the living room
was like my eyeliner I don't know how
iction I baled so hard so hard I was
like this is going to be a great night
and I said you know it's kind of funny I
haven't heard anything from Mr Saturday
yeah um so she asks me and goes hey s do
I need to say something to him should I
text him two hours before the date yeah
okay and so I say you know
what I mean at this rate probably I
would hope that he would but just if you
guys have this good communication who
cares just well not even good
communication it was a few back and
forths and I haven't spoken him in days
so I was like okay I'll just reach out
it's fine F yeah I said hey are we still
on for
tonight he responds about 40 minutes
later if you'd like to still be on for
tonight
now what it's like Chris honestly
honestly I honestly want your opinion
you could be totally honest what's going
through your head when you hear that
that's a crazy game to just play off rip
you you've never met this person before
like that's a crazy game play and it's
definitely you're definitely playing a
game yeah exactly it's like you don't
know him you've never met him in person
and then also the fact that he hadn't
followed up or anything it's not like
this is like you guys have talked about
it and then he's just say are you still
here I like to give everyone the benefit
of the doubt right instantly I was
thinking maybe he's trying to be funny
right but also you don't really do that
if you've never even met the person
person I don't know his his banter I
don't know his personality so I'm just
reading it as what he wrote instantly we
call in the girls well this is the thing
first she tells me and I have the same
reaction as Chris like like and she goes
wait but I need like a second opinion so
yeah so we call reinforcement we call
every girl we know we said how are you
taking it what do you think first
initial thought every single girl was
like red flag red flag red flag they're
like no no no no they said this is not
not the energy you want to be going into
it this is this is foreshadowing for
what it could be in the future and
listen everyone can have their own
interpretation of that read it however
they might but for me call me old school
all right I like someone that is forward
says what they want says yes T happening
this place at this time basic manners
and like it didn't have to be anything
crazy just yes can't wait see you then
would have been
suffice so I start panicking and I'm
pissed cuz I said I got my makeup on I'm
ready to go she was fully ready to go
was looking forward to this one hours
too early but she was ready to go so I
said I need a breather I order some
takeout I said I got to walk so I'm I'm
sitting in the Liv room while she's
figuring this out I'm eating just a
carrot cake alone just waiting for her
to make her decision on what she wants
to do she goes on a walk I come back at
this point I was kind of just like you
know what you kind expect yeah my new
thing is I I always would make excuses
for not bad behavior just sus Behavior
or strange Behavior because I wanted
something so badly and now I'm at that
point where I don't want to settle and
if something doesn't sit right in my gut
and it might sit right in yours but if
it doesn't sit right in my gut then I'm
not going to go for it I'm not going to
waste my time I'm not going to pursue
something that I already have a bad
feeling about right and then I text him
back and I said hey wait can we just say
this is she's about to say the the most
stupid excuse and
so like when I say when she you said it
was good why did you tell me said good
stupid because
it's it is why it's stupid is the fact
that the timing and his response and
then the no message oh here we go it's
so hard so I respond
back
okay sorry
I'm at a work
event I don't think I'll be able to make
it
tonight no regrets don't feel bad I
don't feel anything I'm numb he responds
got
it now listen if he had made a
reservation and place
already I would I would feel different
way this plan was so loose it was barely
discussed it was a random bar like I'm
not ruining his Saturday it was also six
o'clock at night he's fine oh God but
yeah so that was my Saturday day that
was her Saturday that was that here's
the thing I was pretty bummed out that
whole rest of the night I really was
yeah I was kicking myself because I
always do this what get too excited no
well yes
but I started to second guess my choice
in doing that and not going on the date
and then I started to feel bad like I
made the wrong decision and then I
started to feel like I heard his
feelings and then I started and I was
like hold on why do I always feel like
sad or regret for something that doesn't
make me feel comfortable just because
it's making someone else feel
uncomfortable because you're a people
pleaser and you're and you're trying to
make you're trying to find the benefit
of doubt you're trying to also make a
bad situation good and you're trying to
also see like a hypothetic hole that
isn't even you have to also go with you
know when I've always said women have
really good gut instincts if everyone
even hey even Chris he had a gut he knew
immediately that message was just like a
off off message it's it's not it's tough
because you were excited about it so I
think the buildup was kind of such a
bummer that you couldn't follow through
with it and then also you know of course
you're like but what if he was just
trying to make a joke and I just didn't
get it clearly but like you don't know
him he doesn't know you it's weird every
person by way people second guess
themselves but you did the right thing
because that that message was just a
little offhand I also have to say this
it's so easy to feel discouraged after
you've gone on a bad date or something
didn't work out the way you were
expecting and it's really really really
really important to not blame yourself
and just let it be sometimes those types
of people aren't ready for the same
things that you are and that's okay well
I think also you have and everyone does
has standards like people have things
that they require and that's why not
everyone is meant for everybody because
if everyone was meant for everybody
everyone would just like be in the
relationship 24/7 with 100 people but
that's why some person some guy is going
to you know do the things that you want
him to do on the first day like follow
up and give you the and some girls don't
care about that which is totally fine
but like I'm that way too like I want
the more traditional formal yes way of
dating than other people and so look
this guy wasn't that
at all cuz clearly he didn't actually
make a reservation he did not follow up
with anything try you need to look at it
as like you dodged a bullet because at
the end of the day that wasn't going to
be a right match not for him either so
100% I mean you're not you're not the
bullet I'm not saying that you're I am
the bullet you know doing that but you
know in that way but yeah that was and
then now that's why C's giving up so
she's I'm not okay I'm not I'm not but I
am it did switch how I want to approach
dating now now H so I'm not going to get
off the apps was real close to hitting
that delete button the other day she was
really going to delete it okay I'm not
going to get off but I do want to change
my mindset of how I go into
dating literally since my the dawn of
time I'm just kidding literally since I
started dating I always altered myself
physically emotionally personality wise
to what I think that person would like
to see the most like I would dress more
seductively for one date because I would
think that person would be more
attracted to me if I did I would not
speak as much or speak more because I
thought they would like that I would
listen to different kinds of music like
I was always trying to change who I am
so that they liked me and I'm so sick of
trying to find validation through these
strangers that are literally just
getting up putting on shoes and going
and not thinking about it so I I'm going
to try and maybe that's what my problem
has been like I've maybe I haven't found
my person because I'm constantly trying
to Showcase a different version of
myself instead of just who I am just
being who you are and just kind of
letting it naturally come to you and
when it works at the right time but I I
relate to that I mean I I relate to that
in more of like a self-growth sense like
how how I feel like I'm putting myself
in an environment where I'm like go go
go and that's just not who I am and like
that's probably why I'm breaking out
more and like how you're how you do that
with relationships I probably just do
that you know socially a little bit
sometimes and so everyone needs to you
know we all need some fine tuning or
remembering but I do I also do think I
do think the only time you should sort
of you always say this to me and Mom
says this to me that I need to change
how I dress because I come off as
unapproachable when I'm in public no I
don't say okay
cinee by the way that's not really what
what the context was it's not us saying
that she dresses like Wednesday Adams
and everyone's scared of her no I like
to dress like a 12-year-old boy you it
was just well and this is the thing by
the way one time she put on something
that I just recommended did not say she
had to she didn't have to and that was
the dress that every person was coming
up to her saying how gorgeous how like
naturally and beautiful which is you can
it looked like a cupcake and by the way
look how C's dressing now
exactly so she she just she wanted to
dress this way but she thought she
shouldn't cuz she had got dark hair and
decided to be all emo Sophia told me
right before the date she said this is
your pep talk to me don't be such a
black cat like you always are act more
like a golden retriever like me and my
question is do you think when I'm
sitting at these dates that I'm just
being so dark and like Moody and either
way in my defense Scarlet was on the
FaceTime with me on the FaceTime um when
I'm on a date cinee you do you think I'm
approachable do you think I'm inating
yes because the thing is when for me I
already know when I go into a room like
people know this about me I'm almost too
bubbly sometimes I'm like hi like I love
to make everyone like just love me I'm
like hi what's your name where are you
from what's your favorite what's your
zodiac I don't care you kind of go in
very methodical things like a little bit
more slower and then set which is good
but it's not bad I'm not saying it's bad
this is why saying this what are you
saying you aren't that way you're this
way how we talk right now you're always
like this you're more like the golden
than you are the black hat you look like
the black hat you don't you are
internally the golden so and that's
there's no problem with black hats God I
love all she love I love cats and dogs
we accept all cats but my point is is
that you just I feel like you just need
to loosen up on dates don't you don't
need to when you said you were dressing
for guys sometimes we were like oh I
need to like seem a certain way even
it's in the same way as your personality
like you need to just be you know who
you are if and by the and look I'm not
saying that I'm always so like super upy
puppy
but why are you looking at me like that
I'm listening no I'm listening stressing
me out I feel like you think I'm being
mean no no no I appreciate all
constructive criticism you want to be
the black hat you're super hot and
you're hot and it's great and you can
wear you can wear like pants and
t-shirts andb
hats you said I can wear pants and
t-shirts thanks what else would I wear
socks too underwear is that
okay let it breathe it's funny though
because I was talking about this with
Sly and I was like I just want you to
know dad that you have been the biggest
[__] block of our love lives oh yeah we
did bring he actually has been the worst
I'll say living in New York versus LA
I'm not going to get into that what you
were about to jump up but I'm just
saying people in LA are around you know
actors and lesbians a little bit more I
love saying lesbians um so I guess when
they talk about Dad it's not it's not as
frequent as it is in here well what he
was saying just about dating in New York
cuz he used to live here so he somewhat
gets it and from all the stories that
we've told him he brought up a really
good point he said dating in New York
City it's so condensed and there's so
many options especially when you're on a
dating app that guys and girls don't
really feel the need to have to put an
effort for something or follow up or if
something seems like it's too much work
you can just drop that person no problem
because there's going to be a hundred
more options lined up for you so it's
almost like the idea of putting in a
little bit of effort or you know being
chalous towards a woman is harder to
find because why not just you'll find a
gorgeous girl that doesn't really need
all those extra things what he was
saying to us specifically about New York
and La was and I actually when he said
that I go right light like wow he's 100%
correct on this is that when I went on
dates in La even if it was once a month
or maybe every 3 months I actually went
on that date probably another four times
the same guy I don't know if it's
because that the city is
so chaotic and energetic and there's so
many things to do every single day I
think everyone has Peter syndrome here
no one actually wants to grow up no one
wants to grow up but in La people have
to drive like 40 minutes to a date and
so it's you know when you're saying yes
to something you're you're saying yes to
a date I don't even know how to explain
that if that makes sense it's true it's
because it's too convenient to be people
here so so if you're looking to find
true love in New York I don't know I
know everyone's saying move to different
cities but I don't I just got here I
don't want Yeah question who do you
think monogamy in our generation exists
mhm name one name them okay if my
girlfriend's listen to this all your
relationships are great no really don't
you think it's I you know what I think
it's
obviously I feel like less people are
will you know I actually can't say that
cuz I feel like everybody in my life is
engaged in stuff and they want that but
do I feel like every person will stick
like that forever that's what I'm saying
I don't know if it's because of our
parents generation for examp example
when you got married or you found that
person that was it like deal with the
good deal with the bad and that's why
you hear these marriages 30 plus years
they've been together today the idea of
a three-month relationship will short
circuit a man yeah it really will well
yeah but I feel like it's just also
cheating so easy now that's what say
that's probably what it is yeah you go
on Tik
Tok so many good
twers so many gorgeous girls only fans
how about those girls how about those
girls that girlfriend's hire to flirt
with their boyfriend on what are you
talking about so I've seen so many
videos like this where girls will hire
girlfriends will H hire like it can be
just me you come up to me you have a
boyfriend you go hey s can you I'm not
her sister in this
scenario hey Sophia can you DM my
boyfriend just like follow him like a
story whatever it is and say like hi
with a smiley face and see what he says
it's kind of it's a little it's a little
like gotcha thing and so they'll start
talking the guy and some of them block
the girl here's the thing though and
then some of them end up going like
let's go on a date I don't have a
girlfriend no here's the thing if you
have to go through all those troubles
and go through his phone you already
found the answer you don't need to look
for it you already know what's happening
but I I just like for
example we're too stimulated there's too
many things happening there's too many
available options yeah AI did you see
what they're doing now don't
what
what else are they
doing they are making the most
realistic
gorgeous Bots that look like human with
human flesh they have Instagram accounts
they if you pay for their only fans or
whatever they can talk to you on the
phone they can message you back they can
send you private photos so why would any
guy need any real person don't you think
it's don't don't they want someone real
though I I feel like I wouldn't want to
talk to a robot like if I knew I was
talking to AI even if he was super
realistic her is happening guys that
movie her it's coming I think in the
next 10
years anyway that was my tangent and I
would just like to preface this isn't
all men okay we know there's some good
eggs out there and we appreciate you
guys you can DM us just the ones I've
have encountered not so much um wait
actually speaking of
Saturday
oh the plot thi
did I this the same Saturday so by the
way when say she gave up I did too um so
I I said this in my last episode uh with
C I said that I'm kind of burnt out
which is still true I'm very actually I
think I think my last nugget of energy
was Saturday and I'll explain why
because I'm not leaving the house again
so I basically was like I'm I said yeah
actually I wrote this down to that was
saying I canceled all my plans last
minute so I have a problem with
throughout the week accepting every
single plan someone gives me like from
party full or whatever and then the day
comes and I just want to not go and so I
have a hard time so I have a good time I
have an easy time saying yes telling
them I can't go I literally wait till an
hour before cuz I get so nervous yeah
that's but that's normal I think no one
wants to overextend thems CU then when
the plan does come you're going oh man
overextend I didn't I haven't gone out
of the but you don't know what's gonna
happen maybe you woke up that morning
and you got cramps real bad you didn't
know that last week that's true you
never know didn't know cramps were
coming so um Saturday there was a bunch
of events going on and I actually wasn't
feeling that great Saturday and so I
figured you know what I am going to
order in eat that carrot cake my friend
said I should go order it and stay with
your sister that just got and then stay
with s i was great s to hang out with me
we go to bed at the the crisp hour of
9:30 at night Saturday and we're
watching make us sound more sad Sophia I
bad I am read I I like to read at night
so I'm not even looking at my phone
going going I turn off the light I'm
like good night world yeah I don't know
why but I have to give my POV oh I know
you're awake and you know that I'm awake
because even though it's 11:30 at night
we're both active on Tik Tok sending
each other videos and this is that point
of the night where I'm three melatonin
deep I'm kind of seeing stars but I'm
just scrolling I know it's bad but I'm
just scrolling this until I fall asleep
I wasn't using Tik Tok this time cuz I
didn't know what time it was cuz I
really was reading but I probably was
before and it said I was active but um I
don't I don't know why but I just wanted
to check my phone I don't know I was
like literally this close to like being
knocked out and stupid addiction me I
like grab my phone I look at it and it
says like 11:30 and I see a text from my
girlfriend who's out and about and she
says that someone's at a party
m a certain someone and I shoot up in
bed because I've been waiting for this
moment wait what did I do I remember
what you did I actually don't I like
blacked out when iot that message I'm on
Tik Tok about to close my eyes I get a
FaceTime from you oh sit face you I
completely forgot yeah you're sitting in
Pitch Black I'm sitting in Pitch Black
and I
go and you
said we'll call him mysterious Mike yeah
that's a good one mysterious Mike is at
the party do I go do I go do I go I said
turn the curling iron on we're going and
my girlfriend says get your ass here I
FaceTime my other girlfriend she's all
dressed up I go where are you she goes
at my apartment what do you need I go
you're coming with me to this and she
goes so when I tell
you there has never been more chaos in
20 minutes I'm putting Sophia's socks on
as she's drawing a smokey eyeliner wing
I'm pouring her tequila shot and curling
her hair at the same time I've been in
bed I have been antisocial this whole
week pimple cream on pimple cream on
glasses my mouth tape was on my mouth
like it was I was like in it like in bed
you looked good I got ready by 12:30
thing no out the door race out the door
to two tequila shots
out I'm so excited I'm like oh my God I
get to see mysterious mic this I been
waiting for this like I'm so glad he's
in town blah blah
blah I show up I walk in I see to the
BART time like bartender I need another
shot I'm getting really nervous gives me
a shot then he's like I like your I like
your energy we take a shot together now
I've had four shots good stand up
straight walk into the
crowd he
left he wasn't
there not a good night for the Stallone
girls it was bad I get a text from you I
stayed up till 1:30 cuz I said oh I
can't wait I said text me with updates
all I get was he
left I feel dumb and guess what want to
hear the best part want to hear the best
part apparently as I pulled up he drove
off that's how close of a call now do
you believe in Serendipity timing is
everything things are meant to be that
way or do you just think it was bad
timing I think it was I two no I think
bad timing and I think that timing is
everything
though like I feel I feel like I feel
like for our first encounter like that
probably wouldn't have been the best
scenario to meet so that's I myself I
actually seriously admired that you put
yourself out there all the Name of Love
but you know what you shouldn't feel bad
just because it didn't work out the way
that you had intended doesn't mean it
was a failed Mission I think it was a
Learning lesson we learned a lot about
you we learned that you can look great
in 20 minutes you have to be impressed
by that we learned that sometimes you
just got to go for it even if it doesn't
go the way you want you know actually
100% there is a Learning lesson to this
if you're having that do I do I not
moment and your gut is telling you do it
do it just go you know what did it did
it take the last bit of energy I had yes
was it the reason that I probably have
two more pimples on my face Maybe
absolutely but I never got to say what
if and I'm really happy that I didn't
fully just give up on anything like I I
had I still have it there's a fire
there's a kernel that's like barely lit
it's in me it's coming out by the way
you shouldn't if I'm not giving up and
I'm feeling pretty dooo you shouldn't
give up mysterious Mike we're coming for
you okay you escaped this time you
escaped my you SLI through my fingers
this time you snuck by by the hair on my
chinny chin chin but just you bet your
bottom dollar will get you next time
we're going to wear grippy gloves yeah
I'm going to get your legs I'm going to
get your arms you're not going anywhere
sleep tight just kidding um hold on we
went to go see the new Hunger Games yeah
last night mhm
Gabby and I told you hold on Mr snow I
told you if Mr Snow's my
sponsor I volunteer his tribute I
volunteer um hold on S that is so dark
so if someone got if someone else was
called for The Hunger Games and they
said oh snow is your is your person you
would say I volunteer that's me it's not
my name that's me I'm with with him yeah
no that's me but you might
die we might
live but we might live I will say I will
say i' I've seen some photos of this guy
that everyone's talking about and I was
like okay he's goodlooking he's
objectively good-looking but you know
whatever after this fil how old is he he
has a girlfriend respectfully apparently
old is he I don't know Mr snow what's
his
name look at Mr snow no let's just see
what happens just see what happens that
was such a good movie though Chris did
you see the movie I have not I'm not
going to lie it was long and I I don't
love a movie that's over two and a half
hours you know what also really grinded
my gears why do kids that's not
him Mr
snow Sophia it's just a Snowman that's
what he said just look at Mr snow but
here's the thing the movie I have to say
was actually pretty gory like there were
way more killings than in the other ones
it was way more aggressive but what
shocked me even more was right behind us
this couple brought a 2-year-old who was
screaming at every desk oh the entire
film it would be silent someone just
died the baby
go
go not funny and everyone in the
audience was like brings but it was
pretty gory it was gory I actually there
were moments I I was twitching like the
other Hunger Game GES didn't even I'll
say this is probably one of my favorites
huh I'm not going to lie I love all of
them but that that was the top one
what's the lead's name Rachel yes she
ate she's not going to lie she ate also
's
28 yeah You'd Survive You'd Survive the
Hunger Games no I would have not
survived my nail breaks
up my nail I can't it was so no I always
said it was so good it was so good I'm
glad we did on a Sunday like a rainy day
SU day it was nice yeah you know we got
to do that again yeah but probably not
cuz you don't like public theaters are
you excited I'm cooking for you tonight
she is cooking for me tonight y'all and
she's cooking everything that's like
good for my skin and stuff she's so
sweet you can never say I don't care
about you i' never have said even if I
don't actually physically hug you
sometimes you know that love is there
also to all the men watching I'm
domesticated I've been cooking a lot
what I've been cooking a lot I can read
you bedtime story stories that's boring
no it's cute I'm making you a nice
grilled salmon with some roasted carrots
and roasted beets on a bed of arugula
with the honey Dijon vinegret that I
made maybe some chopped almonds fabulous
yeah just fabulous okay why does it say
you're joining Dancing with the
Stars because I am since when I have
been wanting to join Dancing with the
Stars for years you know they asked me
like four years ago really I want to go
on it dad keeps saying no I have a
question would you be pissed if I got on
it with you and we competed against each
other no i' would be so happy I would
love to see who would win and you know
who I think would win me no doubt I
already took one Sal dancing class I'm
ready to go I swear to you actually I'll
tell you why myps are really like so
you're
gonna you're going to base your winnings
off of your ability to dance I think I
pretty good wrong I'll tell you how you
would win through America's Hearts you
know what I would
do I'd start dating the dancer a little
bit of a spark yep between me and my
partner of course you would I'm sorry
all the couples that have done that have
gone through to the semifinals winner
Harry jowy and Riley Arnold is her name
Riley something I'm not gonna lie he's
got two left feet right but they seem to
like each other and then their love
blossomed on TV America wanted to keep
saying it they stayed till like they
were like fifth they got fifth that's
pretty crazy he was not a I'm not I'm
sorry if you're you're not probably
watching this but you're not a great
dancer and she's great would that be
like so like oh my God yeah Alexis Ren
did it yeah yeah I I would do that I
think that's a fun competition show I do
but you're you would probably I just I'm
just obsessed I'm obsessed with the show
out I'm a horrible dancer but I just
think it be you know what just for like
the plot you know sometimes I want to do
things just to sit around a dinner table
and shock people and be like you know I
was dancing with the stars right like
just to throw a little wrench in there
like fun fact was on Dan Stars yeah just
like like I want us do random stuff and
that's not really random that's a it's a
big deal but what competition show would
I
win Special Forces I would you know what
truly shut up shut up if the bathroom
situation was situated need go number
two and private I'm if you guys guys
haven't seen Special Forces they're
basically an8 day
in in military training you do the most
aggressive things ever people are
bleeding punching each other it's crazy
I actually do think I could do well at
that no actually I wouldn't I'd get a
migraine and my contact would pop out
I'm kidding what you what competition
show would you win I think like the
Westminster dog
show like I would kill it if I had a
really good golden retrieve I could kill
that are you joking or the dog show yeah
that's the first thing you thought of
all right well this is just kind of a
venting podcast sine you know what sine
said to me what she said we really need
to structure this out today I go well
the ones that we haven't really
structured out have been pretty funny
good she goes no no no send me the
Google Doc we're going to have it laid
out was this better than the last
one what cuz it was all about me oh is
that why no I didn't say that when and
out shout thank you guys so much for
listening to this week's episode of the
watch
podcast so much for listening to this
episode thank you guys um we'll see you
next Tuesday give us a reading rev that
is so
bad hey everybody welcome back to
another
epode can you just sign off I'm gonna
sign off but I'm gonna strangle you
right after thank you guys so much for
listening to this week's episode of the
unwax podcast with your favorite sisters
s and sopia and we will see you next
Tuesday Ciao Bella